these are the first images of one of a
series of secret rescue flights to the
uk from afghanistan
on board former interpreters and other
staff
who worked for britain's troops and
diplomats
they're seeking a new life in this
country with their families
away from taliban threats it's a
transition
shrouded in secrecy because of security
fears
we're not even allowed to say which
midlands airport this
is the location of quarantine hotels
used by the new arrivals also a secret
i am the witness of eight people whom
killed
around my house by insurgents
they were coming just on motorbike
this former interpreter who we're
calling h
landed with his wife and two children on
an earlier flight
pictured here with british troops he
worked for the uk since 2011.
it's a job the taliban told him to quit
when he didn't they murdered one of his
brothers
then in 2014 he was attacked in the
street
so one person from the front door opened
the door and punched me on my face
as i suddenly broke my nose do you think
they wanted to kill you
of course of course it was
clear that they wanted like to kill me
he's grateful for the chance to relocate
but
is worried for those who've been turned
down despite the uk
offering a more generous resettlement
scheme i can request
the british
government please
do not leave the people who work with
you
do not leave them behind because
if the animals
killing machines come to kabul
they will kill
in afghanistan security forces are under
pressure
as the taliban gains ground it's
prompted former military chiefs also to
urge britain to open its door wider to
former staff
provided they don't pose a security risk
if in doubt get them out and show the
generosity of spirit
that reflects the fundamental nature of
the relationship
between those interpreters and the
british armed forces
back at the quarantine hotel this
british council
employee has benefited from that spirit
along with her husband and three
children
they may get better education
to the uk and also living in a stable
society in prosperius and peaceful
society which we haven't been expected
in afghanistan especially in kabul
daring to dream after escaping a
nightmare
debra haynes sky news